tous ceux d'autres
qui vient dans l'aude
pour cet homme
bien de toi
monique leyrac a été sans aucun doute
une des plus grandes voix du québec
monique leyrac c'est l'idole de diane
dufresne et louise forestier
c'est mon modèle c'était vraiment mon
modèle originaire du quartier rosemont à
montréal mon et clairac à interpréter
dès le début de sa carrière de grandes
chansons dont certaines de félix leclerc
le soir
ma main
et phoenix considéré que sa plus grande
interprète était une grande amie elle
était d'abord la preuve
une des premières sino de cette manière
là aussi importante à chanter nos
auteurs compositeurs que ce soit avec
mon pays de gilles vigneault ou avec
d'autres chansons de claude léveillée
monique leyrac a été applaudi en france
et aux états unis grâce à son immense
talent et je crois que c'était la plus
grande québécoise qui a fait une chanson
du théâtre en même temps cette pionnière
laisse derrière elle un nombre
impressionnant de grandes
interprétations
[Musique]
geffen web radio ce matin 85 chansons
plus de quatre heures de titres et puis
j'ai pas purement vers quoi et puis la
perspective de vivre ça m'ennuie ça
m'ennuie terriblement aussi comédienne
monique leyrac à jouer au petit écran
dans les dames de coeur avant de quitter
la scène en 1992 j'irai pas qu'ils
étaient tous mais vous aurez pu monter
quand même là tandis qu'en 2013
on l'a récompensé pour l'ensemble de son
oeuvre aujourd'hui le québec se souvient
il faut écouter mon et clairac
c'est une leçon de chant c'est m
[Musique]
ici oui c'est des prix mais rate le
cadre non rien
[Musique]